and now my overlooked DVD of the week
and I'm actually so a night trip I
together I hear bitch hot that's right I
took out a blue round like this so much
just this is the Christmas carol and
that's all good day just Christmas cool
you know just that one just that one
there's only warm everyone you with with
a guy right yeah no the one I am talking
about is the one with George Chief Scott
which again I guess he rises the
Guardians makes me think of Christmas
and that was one with Mickey Mouse right
yes yes it was Georgie's got swore it
Mickey Mouse would you put your hand and
a pile of DOC that used to be your best
friend's face you're not cool for bring
joy she's got back from the dead given
mousey they already bought Star Wars
they can buy the corpse of joy see Scott
I like this idea but anyway we digressed
um there's as you know a bajillion
Christmas carols out there this one
really sort gets to me the most mostly
because of George C Scott's performance
I mean this is a guy who was just born
to play Patton and Scrooge pretty much
and for me he's the best he's the best
Cruz because I think when you think of
choice he's got in this role you would
think of him that's great but he's
actually much more reserved and he knows
just the right level to play it that he
is a grump but he's not the most
miserable person in the world even
though I think the script tries to write
him whispers his screams the sort of is
know know what I like is that he will
you know I mind my favorite one of my
favorite scenes in the whole movie is
his introduction when the nephew comes
in and says Merry Christmas uncle and he
just does a turn but like are you
talking to me and then he just starts
laughing like just such a genuine
laughing um it's the only genuine humbug
I've ever heard out of out of us courage
because it's very hard to make that word
sound legit but he just laughs it and it
just he sells it throughout the entire
film and the rest of it
good and they do some very creative
stuff say like with the ghost of
Christmas future which is always the
most fun ghost you know that's always
when you can get the most creative with
and the most creepy with and the most
creepy was still Pete it's the only one
that's smoked - in Disney he was totally
chomping on this today you know we
should have made that to see the Disney
one it is good the movie man they're
screwed the uncles proved one not the
the Mickey Mouse oh I'm not the Jim
Carrey Disney Christmas the cartoon one
is actually more subtle than the one
with the Jim Carrey which is also a
cartoon but again we're inside tacton it
mostly follows the story is the first
one I saw that follow the story closer
than other versions did and they had
seems that I remember seeing I was
younger just like oh I I don't remember
this I don't recall seeing this any
other versions I've seen now everybody
of course tries to tell the story word
for word as close as they can and this
one does take liberties and again it's
not perfect there are flaws in it there
either one or two elements mind
liberties particularly I hate strict
adaptations of the books I wish any
screenwriter that wants to copy it word
for word and be like I'm gonna use every
single exact scene and just read the
book yeah I'm like like people go nuts
for things like Lord the Rings like
helps didn't come in and house deep in
the your job is to make a movie it's not
to retell the book okay yeah it's not
just tell the blog it's you if the
changes are better than they're always
you know worth it now where the change
is better somewhere let the stuff like
they play around some of the ages of the
characters in which they do in a lot of
other versions - I mean the stuff they
changing this for and stuff they usually
change in other versions um you know but
one of the things I like like the ghost
of Christmas future which I thought was
very clever was always constantly in the
distance you know he's far away so you
can never quite see him and he always
sort of float by and I thought the
future the go center gets closer and
closer
as well and I like I like it's the you
know that horrible looming of what's to
come and you know the fear of been
getting closer and closer but again for
me the big it does have good atmosphere
sometimes the acting is overacting or
under acting at times but the real
selling point is George see Scott if you
just want to see an unbelievable scene
in in A Christmas Carol adaptation look
at the scene where he is looking at his
father in the past now as an old man
probably the same age as his father now
looking at him yell at his younger self
and the face he gives that father is
such an unbelievable face of such an
unbelievable performance he's my
favorite Scrooge and I think because of
that it's my favorite version even
though there's probably versions that
are closer or do you know have better
ideas or something it really is his
performance that what I think of Scrooge
I think of him and Scrooge McDuck yes
III think you're touching on something
which is and it sounds so Elementary but
I think a lot of Christmas carols get
this wrong is you have only two
characters you need to successfully pull
off in the Christmas Carol you need a
good Scrooge and you at least need a
decent Cratchit you know a Warner is the
Cratchit yeah and I'm always amazed that
it's such a simple answer in so many of
them I think just get it wrong the
Scrooge is either too grumpy or he's not
powerful enough or he's too kind of to
our tuna yet too whiny or too powerful
to I think the most the the crach the
cratchits are always a similar thing you
know they're either so browbeaten they
have no character or they have you know
they essentially just are just there as
a plot device which is always what Tiny
Tim is but I can I can give that a pass
all Tiny Tim needs to do is sit there
deliver is one line this tiny Tom is
awful by the way in this movie it's a
horrible Tiny Tim I'm sorry I'm sure
you've grown up now but you were awful
it's one of the worst Tiny Tim Merry
Christmas
poor child actor but I
love this version but the Tiny Tim is
ratchet I will say this they do make him
look sick which is something rare you
see for tiny yeah my problem with Tiny
Tim's is they're always supposed to be
dying in yet they obviously look like
they just got prance Tunde you know
thrown on the set you know and you know
with rosy cheeks and everything I was
like just a line I will say this this
looks like a dying kid but you know he
acts like he's already dead but the the
Scrooge in this film cuz I agree with
you is another reason why else like the
ouster sim version that is a good one
too um both of those Scrooge's I get the
feeling a little more with the Alastair
sim but I think it's buried deep down in
there particularly seeing a mention
where he laughs there was a part of them
that I think they're self-aware to some
certain degree that they're playing
their intended audience which is
something a lot of Scrooge's don't get a
lot of scrutiny I get it's like I'm evil
I'm bad I'm grumpy
there's something about Alastair sim and
George see Scott that they have that
little grin that mischievous sort of
sneer almost like when they say things
you know like they should be boiled in
their own pudding that they know that
what they're saying is so outrageous
that they're looking for the rise out of
someone else like yeah they're like a
Christmas but I really also would just
want to get a rise out of you like I'm
gonna play this up so much just because
I don't like the holiday who dance
puppets dance you know and that mistress
quality is something that I think makes
Scrooge in some ways endearing because
all you've done is taken that quality
than mr. his quality for bad in the
first part of the story and Dickens I
mean twists it on its edge so at the end
he's still mischievous he comes in
faking chewing get out
hiding the toys he's a dick it's the
same he's a nice dick the same reason
you like the Grinch you had to have some
likability and I will say the most
important thing if this is something
weird when there is the Grinch in
particular that's a great example
because when the Grinch is stealing
things that Tim hurry we'd say Tim Curry
now the Grinch came first but that Tim
Curry grin like from home alone too he
loves his job
late you have to have some love of what
you're doing and some love of mischief
to make that work on both angles good
and bad and I'll give a great example
one where I I think went too far a lot
of people are gonna hate me for it
the Michael Caine in the Muppet one I
don't think it's a good Scrooge and
mother died but it was a bad square um
and the thing that really annoys me and
that this isn't necessarily his fault
but that Scrooge was written in a way
where he was supposed to have no
humanity at all at first I don't think
that's right because it's you know it's
written that Scrooge gives Cratchit a
day off that is the little bit of
kindness that is still in there and in
the Muppet one they say that you know if
you close down it'll actually be more
profitable if you do this and that's why
he gives in and that is not right that
is a real crime in my opinion there
always is still I mean that was the
point of the Dickens sale there always
is still that love of Christmas buried
underneath there when he sees old
Fezziwig you know in the past you know
when he reminisces about his sister then
humanity was always there is Barry I
just had to be brought up again yeah you
know when he realizes made a mistake
throwing loved his life out you know it
it always is there and I think to just
dehumanize him is the biggest mistake
bad Christmas carols meg sorry the one
you picked in the Alastair sim I think
are good I you know what we're here the
Disney one is really good too it doesn't
go to and the Disney one does the same
thing and it's very short but you know
what it gets the most important element
and they hit every modern economy of
storytelling if all Christmas carols
could be 30 minutes long the world would
be a better place because that film hit
every single note it needed to did it
with cartoon characters we know unlike
and gabe scrooge mcduck a real character
i mean duck tales came out after that
that we launched Scrooge as a character
and it was the same thing he had
humanity when he goes back in time and
sees old Fezziwig he's genuinely happy
when he sees himself breaking up he's
like you know
oh no oh you should do it's more simple
what change Oh Ellen young he's hurting
is it okay yeah see he's still I think
he is I do god I hope he is I'd be
depressed that would be sad no and a
great Ellen young but like Alan young
Scrooge and it's his best Scrooge
performance ever I mean DuckTales was
for fun you don't get a lot of emotion
you feel like actual emotion he nailed
it in that production and great casting
- I know it sounds ridiculous how do you
cast a Disney movie but they cast all
the proper characters for who they
should I mean let's be honest Mickey
Mouse has Cratchit is genius do
you have like your character large giant
as Christmas present Jiminy Cricket is
Christmas past you know I mean it's like
this period so but I mean so that's two
good Christmas carols right breathe
great three is the inclusive the outlet
I'll stay around one so you got more tea
party yeah so there that's like three
fast reviews for you there but I you
know the length of the walk Dorsey's got
is often not overlooked did not looked
at nearly enough and I think it's
definitely worth checking out so go see
it enjoy it and then watch Scrooge
McDuck speed